Esiste un legame profondo tra la tecnologia che utilizziamo ogni giorno e il modo in cui la nostra mente conserva i ricordi che va ben oltre il classico esempio secondo cui da quando tutti usiamo la rubrica dello smartphone nessuno è più in grado di memorizzare nemmeno un numero di telefono.
Qualche tempo fa ho partecipato ad una interessante conversazione con un'amica nella quale abbiamo confrontato le nostre visioni sull'importanza di conservare e soprattutto rileggere i messaggi scambiati via chat.
Da quella discussione sono scaturite poi tutta una serie di riflessioni e approfondimenti che si sono ampliati e alla fine si sono trasformati nell'episodio di oggi.
Buon ascolto!
benvenuti su pensieri in codice il podcast dove si ragiona da informatici con valerio galan
Prima di procedere con l'argomento di oggi, voglio dirti che, lo so, non pubblico un episodio da tre mesi e questo mi dispiace.
Primo perché sto venendo meno al tacito accordo che abbiamo io e te, nel quale tu ti impegni ad ascoltare e supportare questo podcast, ed io a produrre, non diciamo quattro, ma almeno un episodio al mese.
Secondo perché pensieri in codice è il mio modo di organizzare i pensieri, appunto, di condividere ciò che penso, di raccontare le cose che ritengo interessanti e di coltivare il mio rapporto con te che mi segui.
Ora, non sto qui a giustificarmi per l'assenza, tanto non credo sia né utile né necessario.
Ma voglio renderti partecipe del fatto che in questi mesi sono stato impegnato su vari progetti, tutti bene o male legati a Pensieri in Codice o al podcasting in generale.
Il primo è sicuramente il rifacimento del sito ufficiale di questo podcast.
Con il supporto di Simone Pizzi, fondatore di Runtime Radio, ho riprogettato e riscritto da zero tutto il sito di Pensieri in Codice.
Ora l'aspetto è molto più accattivante, dinamico e sicuramente più usabile.
Le informazioni sono organizzate meglio, il player è stato enormemente potenziato.
Insomma, sono piuttosto orgoglioso del risultato e mi piacerebbe che ci facessi un giro, così per darmi un feedback.
Lo trovi sempre all'indirizzo pensierincodice.it, mi raccomando con due i.
Poi ho rivisto e migliorato tutti gli automatismi legati sempre a pensieri in codice.
Ad esempio ho sviluppato un bot Telegram che pubblica nel gruppo della community dei quiz sull'informatica e sugli argomenti trattati negli episodi passati.
Ovviamente ti invito a provare anche questo e quindi a unirti al nostro gruppo di discussione che trovi sempre sul sito o cercando direttamente su Telegram.
Poi ancora sto partecipando ad un altro interessante podcast, sempre con gli amici di Runtime, che si intitola Good Vibrations, nel quale discutiamo ogni due settimane di vibe coding o più in generale di sviluppo software tramite l'utilizzo di intelligenza artificiale.
Simone, Alex, Luca e gli altri di Runtime sono persone estremamente interessanti e socievoli e con loro stiamo pianificando molte altre attività da fare nei prossimi mesi.
Ah, e mi hanno anche intervistato.
Una bella serie di domande da parte di Simone che mi hanno permesso di esprimere un po' di cose su pensieri in codice che di solito non dico durante gli episodi.
Ancora...
Sto implementando nel feed di questo podcast una funzionalità nuova del podcasting 2.0 che si chiama Soundbyte e che serve ad individuare spezzoni interessanti degli episodi per farne degli shorts o dei trailer.
Proprio a questo proposito ho scritto un set di software per sfruttare questa funzionalità per generare delle clip e pubblicarle automaticamente sui social.
Si tratta di un'app e due script che coprono tutta la filiera di produzione.
Si parte da un'app in Swift per macOS, che ho sviluppato insieme ad Alex Raccuglia, e si prosegue con due script in Python che lavorano in serie.
Magari ne parliamo meglio in un prossimo episodio.
Il punto però è che ho sviluppato tutto in linguaggi completamente nuovi per me.
Quindi, tanta roba.
Ovviamente tutto in vibe coding, ma ciò non toglie che la cosa abbia richiesto tempo e fatica.
Lo so, è un sacco di roba e non posso certamente approfondirla tutta oggi, ma se ti interessa saperne di più ti lascio nella descrizione dell'episodio tutti i link a tutto, così magari vai a dare un'occhiata e mi fai sapere.
Ora però mi fermo qui e passiamo all'argomento di oggi, se no questo episodio non inizia mai.
E, cosa importantissima, ascolta l'episodio fino alla fine perché ci sarà una bella sorpresa subito prima della conclusione.
Hai mai riflettuto sul fatto che da quando abbiamo accesso a tecnologie in grado di memorizzare informazioni come app di messaggistica o fotocamere digitali, sembra sempre più naturale l'idea che ricordare il più possibile sia meglio che dimenticare?
Che avere più informazioni sul nostro passato significhi automaticamente essere più vicini alla verità riguardo un evento che abbiamo vissuto, un discorso a cui abbiamo partecipato o una sensazione che abbiamo sperimentato?
Questa convinzione si basa su un semplice fatto.
Oramai, sempre più spesso, il passato, almeno in parte, è effettivamente ancora lì a nostra disposizione.
precisamente, diligentemente e immutabilmente cristallizzato nei nostri dispositivi, nel cloud o in generale in qualche archivio digitale.
Basta aprire una chat e possiamo rileggere facilmente conversazioni di mesi fa, di anni fa, parola per parola, come se quel momento fosse rimasto sospeso, sempre disponibile, pronto per essere consultato ogni volta che ne abbiamo voglia.
Nelle gallerie dei nostri smartphone, poi, abbiamo decine o migliaia di fotografie, filmati e screenshot che immortalano attimi importanti delle nostre vite e di coloro che abbiamo intorno.
E vogliamo parlare di cosa pubblichiamo sui social?
Attimi fugaci delle nostre giornate, avvenimenti che hanno suscitato in noi emozioni particolari, esternazioni di affetto, ricordi che vogliamo condividere con il mondo?
Tutto questo è estremamente semplice e accessibile.
E come conseguenza naturale, piano piano, ci siamo convinti che sia meglio così.
Che non sia più necessario né desiderabile affidarci alla nostra memoria.
Perché tanto possiamo andare a recuperare cosa è stato davvero detto o scritto o è accaduto con massima precisione e minimo sforzo.
Ma se questa convinzione non fosse poi così corretta?
A volte sarà accaduto anche a te che, rileggendo una chat o riascoltando un vocale, il discorso non ti appaia perfettamente chiaro come lo ricordavi.
Oppure che le sensazioni che provi riguardando un video non coincidano esattamente con quello che ti aspettavi.
Ti potrebbe essere capitato di dare interpretazioni diverse a parole e conversazioni del passato.
arrivando perfino a stravolgerne il significato per poi renderti conto di aver basato comportamenti e reazioni successive su premesse e supposizioni che ora ti appaiono sbagliate o fuori fuoco.
E quel maxievento dove ricordavi di aver incontrato quel vecchio compagno di scuola?
Come era vestito?
Aveva la barba?
Tu lo cerchi nella galleria, scorri centinaia di foto, eppure non riesci a trovarne una sua che riguardi quel momento.
E allora inizi a dubitare.
Forse era un altro periodo o un altro evento.
Stiamo parlando quasi di un paradosso.
Abbiamo tutte le informazioni archiviate, una precisione assoluta, un accesso rapido e semplice, eppure a volte il risultato è che manca qualcosa rispetto ai nostri ricordi.
Oppure che le due fonti non corrispondono perfettamente.
In realtà, a pensarci, la sensazione è un po' che in qualche modo rileggere, riascoltare o rivedere non sembra essere la stessa cosa che ricordare.
È come se tra quello che ricordi che è accaduto e quello che invece è stato registrato ci sia una certa differenza.
Ecco, se anche a te è mai capitato di provare qualcosa del genere, sappi che è perfettamente normale e la colpa non è della tua memoria che fa cilecca, al contrario dipende invece dal fatto che, con la complicità della tecnologia, stiamo iniziando a trattare i ricordi nel modo sbagliato.
Per capire appieno il discorso che voglio fare oggi con te, è importante, prima di addentrarci nell'argomento tecnologico, fare una digressione sul funzionamento della memoria, quella umana intendo, e sulla sua peculiare capacità di lasciare andare, di dimenticare.
Siamo abituati a pensare alla nostra memoria come a qualcosa che dovrebbe somigliare ad un archivio, qualcosa che conserva le informazioni nel modo più fedele possibile e che, se funzionasse davvero bene, non dovrebbe perdere mai nulla.
Ci piacerebbe che una volta imparata una nozione questa ci rimanesse per sempre, così come ci sforziamo di memorizzare le date dei compleanni, le cose da fare, le scadenze.
A scuola ci facevano perfino studiare le poesie a memoria proprio per farci esercitare questa capacità.
E dunque noi viviamo ogni dimenticanza come un fallimento.
come un difetto del nostro sistema mnemonico, come un problema da risolvere.
Eppure questa visione è in realtà errata.
O meglio, c'è un certo sottoinsieme di informazioni che possiamo riuscire a tenere bene a mente per tutta una serie di ragioni, che magari approfondiremo tra un po'.
Ma in linea generale, il nostro cervello non è fatto per ricordare le cose esattamente, in modo esatto.
Nel libro Perché dimentichiamo, il professor Sergio della Sala ci spiega che, secondo recenti studi neuroscientifici, dimenticare non è qualcosa che accade nonostante la memoria, bensì qualcosa che accade proprio perché la memoria possa funzionare.
Nelle prime pagine del libro, della Sala ci racconta una piccola disavventura vissuta con un suo amico che si era offerto di andarlo a prendere in aeroporto.
All'uscita dai terminal, una volta giunti al parcheggio, i due si rendono conto che l'auto è sparita.
Poiché l'amico è comprensibilmente nervoso, il professore gli chiede se vuole passare a comprare dei tranquillanti in farmacia, e d'improvviso il malcapitato ricorda di aver parcheggiato proprio davanti alla farmacia per andare a comprare il dentifricio.
Questo breve episodio descrive quel genere di piccola amnesia che sarà capitata sicuramente a
tutti, almeno una volta nella vita, quando ci chiediamo se abbiamo chiuso il gas o dato le mandate alla porta di casa o se ieri abbiamo acquistato il latte oppure no.
Ad una prima occhiata superficiale questo fenomeno potrebbe sembrare un difetto, un errore.
Ma, alla luce di quanto descritto nel libro del professor della sala, appare chiaro che si tratta invece di un meccanismo indispensabile perché la nostra memoria funzioni correttamente.
Cosa accadrebbe in realtà se ricordassimo ogni singola posizione in cui abbiamo parcheggiato l'auto ogni singolo giorno che ci siamo recati in ufficio?
A cosa servirebbe ricordare tutte le volte in cui abbiamo chiuso la porta di casa o il gas in passato?
Invertendo il punto di vista possiamo dire che l'oblio non è affatto una mancanza, ma una strategia.
Un modo attraverso cui il nostro sistema cognitivo riesce a mantenere equilibrio, selezionando quello che conta e lasciando andare il resto.
Se non dimenticassimo mai alcunché, infatti, non riusciremmo più a distinguere quello che è rilevante da quello che non lo è e non saremmo in grado di dare un ordine alle informazioni che abbiamo nella nostra testa.
Nell'esempio dell'auto, se tutte le posizioni dei vari parcheggi del passato restassero disponibili allo stesso livello, finirebbero per sovrapporsi le une alle altre.
E in tal modo, invece di aiutarci a ricordare dove dobbiamo cercare l'auto oggi, la memoria inizierebbe a confonderci e ostacolarci.
Questo meccanismo della dimenticanza ovviamente non riguarda solo il parcheggio o la serratura di casa.
Esso governa, in generale, il modo in cui funziona qualsiasi ricordo che transita per la nostra mente.
Ogni volta che ricordiamo qualcosa infatti non stiamo recuperando tutto quello che è accaduto, ma stiamo da un lato selezionando quello che ci serve e dall'altro scartando tutto il resto.
Ciascun ricordo non è una registrazione dell'intero avvenimento, non è un filmato che possiamo rivedere quando vogliamo.
Esso è in realtà una selezione di particolari che hanno per noi più valore rispetto a tutto il resto.
E questo equilibrio tra quello che resta e quello che viene lasciato indietro è la caratteristica che rende la memoria un qualcosa di utilizzabile nel quotidiano.
Certamente non un archivio perfetto, ma un'abilità estremamente funzionale per i nostri bisogni.
La nostra memoria dunque non conserva le cose così come sono successe, come se fosse una specie di telecamera.
Quello che realmente fa piuttosto è molto più simile al creare un proprio racconto dell'evento.
In un racconto non si riportano mai semplicemente i fatti, ma volenti o nolenti...
si dà una forma a ciò che è accaduto, scegliendo una direzione per la narrazione e costruendo un senso ben preciso per l'avvenimento.
Come ci chiarisce più volte il professor della sala, quello che conserviamo nei nostri ricordi non sono gli eventi in sé, ma il significato che quegli eventi hanno avuto per noi.
I neuroni si connettono fra loro spontaneamente formando reti complesse.
E questo processo è guidato dall'interazione con ciò e chi ci circonda.
Infatti, esperienze e stimoli sensoriali rafforzano o modulano queste connessioni.
La memoria è costituita da strati e strati di ricordi che si sovrappongono, si mescolano, spariscono e a volte riappaiono.
Il tutto influenzato da come quei ricordi li apprendiamo, da come li organizziamo, da quanto spesso li rievochiamo e via discorrendo.
Ci sarebbe tantissimo da approfondire su questo argomento, ma l'episodio non può durare sei ore, quindi se ti interessa saperne di più ti lascio il link affiliato al libro perché dimentichiamo in descrizione.
ciò che invece serve capire a noi oggi è che ogni ricordo fin dall'inizio non è mai completo è già da subito il risultato di una selezione, di una riduzione e di una rielaborazione in pratica è una sintesi soggettiva e siccome non è un qualcosa che arriva dopo ma è proprio il modo nel quale il ricordo viene creato
Quello che a noi resta non è il passato così com'è accaduto, ma il passato così come lo abbiamo filtrato, riorganizzato e reso coerente rispetto a quello che in quel momento aveva senso per noi.
In pratica, anche quando abbiamo la sensazione di ricordare qualcosa con precisione.
Quello che conserviamo nella mente non è mai una copia esatta del passato, ma è sempre la nostra versione di quel passato.
Una versione che funziona non perché esaustiva e completa, ma perché utile per noi.
Quando torniamo con la memoria ad un nostro ricordo, dunque, non stiamo recuperando semplicemente qualcosa che è rimasto cristallizzato e che possiamo rimettere in play a piacimento.
In realtà stiamo facendo un'operazione molto più instabile.
Stiamo ricostruendo una nostra versione di un evento, di un discorso, di un'immagine o quello che è, a partire da un delicato reticolo di connessioni.
Ogni ricostruzione da un lato consolida il reticolo mettendolo in evidenza tra altri migliaia, ma dall'altro...
lo modifica e lo riadatta introducendo piccoli cambiamenti, anche se noi siamo convinti che esso sia sempre fedele a se stesso e alla realtà.
Insomma, più accediamo all'informazione in momenti e condizioni differenti e più questa acquista o perde dettagli e particolari.
E la cosa più interessante è che tutti gli adattamenti dipendono essenzialmente da noi stessi.
Con il passare del tempo infatti noi viviamo nuove esperienze, capiamo cose che prima ignoravamo, vediamo sotto una luce diversa persone, situazioni, perfino noi stessi.
E tutto questo interferisce inevitabilmente nel modo in cui torniamo e reinterpretiamo il passato.
In pratica ciò che è veramente cambiato ogni volta che rievochiamo un ricordo siamo noi.
È il modo in cui noi vediamo i fatti del passato, il modo in cui li colleghiamo, il significato che attribuiamo loro, il punto di vista da cui stiamo guardando.
La memoria non è, quindi, un archivio immutabile, ma un processo dinamico che si trasforma con l'esperienza.
L'azione di ricordare non è un gesto neutro, perché nel momento stesso in cui proviamo a recuperare qualcosa, quel qualcosa passa di nuovo attraverso di noi, e questa rielaborazione non avviene nel contesto originale, ma nel presente.
avviene nel momento in cui stiamo pensando nuovamente a quel ricordo, tenendo conto di tutto ciò che nel frattempo è cambiato.
L'informazione passa attraverso la nuova versione di noi, passa attraverso quello che sentiamo adesso, passa attraverso il contesto in cui ci troviamo adesso e, soprattutto, passa attraverso il significato che noi oggi diamo a quell'esperienza.
Per questo motivo quello che chiamiamo ricordo non è mai semplicemente il passato, ma il passato così come riusciamo a ricostruirlo ora, con tutte le sue imprecisioni, distorsioni e addirittura invenzioni.
O forse sarebbe più corretto dire le nostre imprecisioni, distorsioni e invenzioni.
Perché se il ricordo non viene direttamente recuperato ma ricostruito, allora nel momento in cui mancheranno dei pezzi, la memoria tenderà a colmare quei vuoti con qualcosa che sia plausibile, coerente e compatibile con il resto della storia.
Quando c'è da raccontare una storia, questa non può essere lacunosa o frammentaria.
Il cervello umano odia le cose incomplete, quelle che non può spiegare.
Pertanto è bravissimo a riempire gli spazi attingendo ad altre fonti, come ad esempio la fantasia.
Solo che questa operazione la fa nel momento presente, in quello del recupero, partendo da presupposti e condizioni differenti da quelli che vigevano al momento in cui gli eventi si sono verificati, partendo dal nostro noi attuale.
E il risultato sarà qualcosa che sicuramente avrà senso, ma che molto probabilmente non sarà esattamente vero in senso stretto.
Veniamo dunque al cuore dell'episodio di oggi.
So che la premessa è stata lunghissima, però era indispensabile per capire il mio punto di vista.
Se, come abbiamo detto, da una parte ci siamo evoluti con una memoria che funziona selezionando, sintetizzando e ricostruendo,
Dall'altra siamo dotati di strumenti che, almeno in apparenza, fanno esattamente il contrario, cioè conservano tutto senza lasciar sfumare nulla.
Si tratta di qualcosa che, ad una prima occhiata, ci fa pensare fantastico, un vantaggio enorme.
In qualsiasi momento possiamo andare a recuperare con precisione qualsiasi ricordo di cui abbiamo bisogno.
Beh, peccato però che poi all'atto pratico non sia proprio così.
Quando torniamo a rileggere una conversazione, riascoltare un discorso o riguardare l'album di un evento, ciò che stiamo facendo in realtà è cercare di far combaciare due informazioni che non sono perfettamente sovrapponibili.
Da un lato c'è il ricordo naturale, impreciso e soggettivo, e dall'altro quello digitale, perfetto ed immutabile.
Ed è qui che si viene a creare una sorta di scollamento tra la percezione ricordata e quella attuale.
Ciò che abbiamo in un archivio digitale è un'informazione estremamente precisa, inoppugnabile e inclemente, ma allo stesso tempo incompleta.
Una riproduzione sicuramente fedele di un accadimento, ma che ne rappresenta solo una parte.
Una conversazione o un evento, infatti, non sono solo parole o immagini.
bensì sono anche il momento in cui avvengono, come ci sentiamo mentre parliamo, quello che sta accadendo intorno, il rapporto che abbiamo con le altre persone in quel preciso istante.
Parlo di un contesto che non può venire immortalato in nessuna registrazione digitale.
Si possono conservare le immagini, le parole.
L'ordine è l'ora in cui sono state registrate, ma non il significato che avevano per noi in quel preciso istante.
E quindi, quello che resta è una traccia che sembra completa, ma che in realtà ha già perso una parte fondamentale di quello che era.
E l'ambiguità che la tecnologia sembra eliminare...
viene in realtà semplicemente spostata in un punto meno ovvio e più infido.
In pratica esattamente come accade per la memoria naturale quando riguardiamo un ricordo digitale stiamo recuperando una traccia parziale e la stiamo completando con informazioni di adesso.
con quello che siamo diventati, con quello che sappiamo oggi, con il modo in cui oggi guardiamo quella relazione, quella persona o quella versione di noi stessi.
Di fatto le conversazioni o le immagini che vogliamo rievocare non sono più legate indissolubilmente al momento in cui le abbiamo vissute.
bensì diventano il punto di partenza per una nuova interpretazione, che in un certo senso ricomincia da capo a nuove condizioni.
Il paradosso a cui volevo arrivare dunque sta nel fatto che ci siamo convinti che rileggere o riguardare
sia sempre e comunque una forma più affidabile di rievocare un ricordo rispetto al conservarlo nella nostra mente.
Vediamo lo strumento tecnologico come una sorta di memoria più potente e più precisa, come se le due cose viaggiassero sullo stesso asse e ricordare fosse il modo fallace, mentre recuperare la traccia digitale fosse la correzione ad una sorta di incapacità naturale.
Peccato che attingere alla memoria umana o a quella digitale non sono due versioni più o meno efficienti dello stesso gesto.
Anzi, come abbiamo visto, sono semplicemente operazioni molto diverse, ognuna con le proprie specificità.
Quando ricordiamo, per quanto il ricordo possa essere fragile, distorto o incompleto...
Stiamo comunque tornando a qualcosa che abbiamo vissuto dall'interno, qualcosa che per noi era immerso in un contesto, in uno stato emotivo, in una continuità di esperienza che lo rendeva parte di una storia.
La rilettura invece prende un frammento di quella storia e lo stacca da tutto il resto, lo estrae dal suo contesto e lo porta forzatamente nel presente, lo isola dal noi del passato e chiede al noi del presente di reinserirlo in un nuovo spazio diverso.
La memoria naturale, anche se imprecisa, è sempre coerente con il proprio racconto e con noi.
Ogni rievocazione influisce sul ricordo stesso, ma le modifiche sono un processo graduale e consistente dall'inizio al presente.
La memoria digitale invece si forma all'esterno rispetto a noi ed è immutabile.
Le informazioni che vengono immediatamente perse non sono mai transitate al nostro interno, non siamo stati noi a decidere di scartarle o riadattarle con il tempo.
Quando rileggiamo allora non siamo di fronte ad un qualcosa che poco a poco è cambiato e si è evoluto insieme a noi, ma ad un punto fisso nel tempo che, per quanto abbiamo detto fino ad ora, è difficile da interpretare correttamente per il noi del presente.
Al giorno d'oggi la tecnologia ci sta spingendo sempre più a pensare che perdere qualcosa sia un problema e che non perdere nulla sia meglio che lasciare andare, come se bastasse conservare di più per capire di più.
Il che ha senso in molti contesti oggettivi, dove documenti, archivi e registri precisi sono di innegabile importanza, ma non certo in quelli soggettivi, che coinvolgono emozioni e ricordi.
Questa idea che più informazioni abbiamo sul passato e più ci avviciniamo alla verità è diventata talmente naturale che quasi non la mettiamo più in discussione.
Quante foto scattiamo e quanti video giriamo ogni volta che vogliamo imprimerci qualcosa nella memoria?
Il professor della sala però ci spiega che la memoria umana funziona bene non nonostante il fatto che dimentichi ma proprio grazie a questa sua caratteristica.
Tutto si basa su un equilibrio molto preciso tra ciò che viene mantenuto e ciò che viene lasciato andare.
Al contrario, i sistemi artificiali tendono a fare esattamente l'opposto.
Conservano tutto senza operare alcuna selezione.
E questa differenza cambia completamente il modo in cui le due forme di memoria producono significato.
Nel nostro caso, dimenticare serve a orientarsi, a mantenere solo ciò che è utile, mentre in un sistema che non dimentica mai, il rischio è che tutto resti allo stesso piano.
È una questione di dare diverso peso alle cose.
Studi citati nel libro mostrano che in realtà nel momento in cui deleghiamo un ricordo ad un supporto esterno, galleria fotografica dello smartphone ad esempio, noi tendiamo poi a ricordarlo di meno.
Paradossalmente l'informazione viene archiviata su un supporto più preciso e durevole.
Ma noi smettiamo di prestarle la stessa attenzione che avremmo fatto altrimenti.
Come se il nostro sistema interno si rilassasse e smettesse di fare quella selezione che normalmente farebbe.
Negli ultimi tempi il desiderio di non perdere nulla sta diventando sempre più radicato.
Si diffondono in commercio strumenti in grado di registrare tutto ciò che accade, incontri, conversazioni, pensieri ad alta voce.
Si va dagli occhiali con videocamera ai ciondoli con registratore vocale, dagli speaker per videoconferenze ai bot che assistono alle riunioni.
In certi ambiti come quello lavorativo in cui si fanno molti incontri o brainstorming o in caso di difficoltà nel trattenere informazioni ed avvenimenti importanti, strumenti del genere possono certamente essere estremamente utili.
Ma in generale questa deriva ci spinge sempre più verso l'idea sbagliata che nulla debba andare mai perso.
Sta diventando una convinzione talmente forte da sembrare naturale, ma la verità è che non potrebbe essere più distante dalla natura.
Nel romanzo La casa di marzapane di Jennifer Egan...
viene descritto un mondo costruito proprio sulla possibilità di accedere alla propria memoria e addirittura anche a quella collettiva senza alcuna limitazione.
In questo bellissimo romanzo, in cui si incastrano le vicende di molteplici personaggi,
viene descritto uno strumento chiamato Cubo Mandala, che permette a ciascuno di scaricare ogni ricordo accumulato fino a quel momento in uno speciale device a forma di cubo.
Successivamente al download gli utenti possono poi andare a rivedere in comodità tutti i loro ricordi, riguardandoli come dei filmati in soggettiva e muovendosi avanti e indietro tra le registrazioni.
Lo strumento è talmente preciso e potente che è in grado di recuperare anche ricordi che normalmente non sarebbero accessibili perché naturalmente dimenticati.
In questo modo, letteralmente qualsiasi esperienza vissuta dal soggetto può essere rievocata e rivissuta.
All'inizio è una situazione che a molti appare fantastica.
un potenziamento della memoria naturale che la rende perfetta, indelebile e sempre accessibile.
Poco alla volta però il romanzo ci mostra come in realtà non si è affatto così.
A parte i problemi ovvi di privacy nel condividere un dato importante come la propria memoria con gli utenti di un servizio esterno o peggio ancora con una multinazionale, il primo vero limite diventa...
il non sapere cosa farne di tante informazioni.
Ci sono alcuni personaggi del libro che restano sopraffatti dalla quantità di ricordi ai quali hanno accesso dopo il download, altri che ricordano cose che avrebbero preferito dimenticare.
Rifluiscono in loro fiumi di avvenimenti e momenti dolorosi che la loro memoria umana aveva rielaborato e stemperato o situazioni spiacevoli dimenticate riguardo persone incontrate nel corso della vita.
C'è perfino chi arriva a rendersi conto che non tutte le storie meritano di essere raccontate o ricordate e chi si rifiuta di rievocare certi ricordi e si chiede, cito,
Come potrebbe la rivisitazione senza filtri di quei tempi migliorare la storia fornita dal suo semplice ricordo?
Alla fine, le vicende dell'ultimo personaggio si concludono con la consapevolezza che, altra citazione, sapere tutto però è troppo simile a non sapere nulla.
Senza una storia, non c'è che informazione.
Insomma, come già detto, quando hai accesso a tutto, quando ogni esperienza è disponibile nello stesso modo, senza filtri, senza selezione, senza perdita, quello che viene meno non è la quantità di informazioni, è il loro significato.
Certo, noi oggi non siamo ancora a questo livello, ma forse ci stiamo avvicinando e soprattutto, forse, il problema è che ci stiamo convincendo che quello sia l'obiettivo da perseguire.
Passo dopo passo, strumento dopo strumento, stiamo maturando l'idea che l'accumulo di conoscenza sia un qualcosa di unicamente positivo, sia il meglio da fare in ogni circostanza.
Quello a cui dovremmo invece pensare quando usiamo i nostri giocattoli tecnologici è che l'accumulo senza significato non si trasforma automaticamente in valore, piuttosto resta soltanto rumore di fondo.
Forse il punto, alla fine, è che questa storia non riguarda solo la memoria e i ricordi.
Forse riguarda il modo in cui il passato continua a persistere nelle nostre vite.
Un tempo, semplicemente, una parte enorme di quello che ci accadeva spariva.
non tutta insieme, non di colpo, ma spariva abbastanza da lasciare spazio al resto.
Le conversazioni si confondevano, i dettagli si allentavano, certe frasi smettevano di essere così nitide e, dentro questo lento sfumare, c'era qualcosa che abbiamo sempre trattato come un difetto, senza considerarne gli aspetti positivi.
Il passato, per continuare a esistere per noi,
non può restare identico a se stesso, deve cambiare forma, deve smettere di essere presenza e diventare racconto, deve perdere qualcosa per poter restare con noi in un altro modo.
Ed è forse proprio questo che adesso stiamo iniziando a mettere in discussione nel momento in cui ci abituiamo all'idea che nulla debba più sfumare.
Che ogni parola possa essere recuperata, che ogni traccia possa tornare disponibile, che ogni momento possa restare lì, pronto ad essere riaperto come se il tempo in fondo non avesse più il diritto di fare il suo lavoro.
Ed è chiaro perché questa promessa ci affascini tanto, perché ci rassicura, ci dà l'impressione che finalmente qualcosa possa smettere di sfuggirci, ci dà l'illusione del controllo.
Non sarete più costretti ad affidarvi a quella memoria instabile, selettiva e perfino inaffidabile di cui siete naturalmente dotati, ci sta dicendo la moderna tecnologia.
Eppure, forse, è proprio qui il concetto più difficile da vedere.
Se la memoria umana non è mai stata fatta per conservare tutto, ma per trattenere quello che conta abbastanza da poterne ricavare un senso, allora una memoria che non lascia andare nulla non è semplicemente una memoria più forte.
È qualcosa di diverso, qualcosa che rischia di non somigliare più a ciò che fino ad oggi abbiamo chiamato ricordare, qualcosa che potrebbe non essere per forza adatto al nostro modo di funzionare.
È qualcosa di diverso, qualcosa che rischia di non somigliare più a ciò che fino ad oggi abbiamo chiamato ricordare.
Qualcosa che potrebbe non essere per forza adatto al nostro modo di funzionare, perché ricordare, per come lo facciamo noi, non è mai stato il semplice fatto di avere accesso al passato, ma un modo di trasformarlo abbastanza da poterci convivere, da poterlo riportare al presente senza esserne schiacciati, da farne una storia e non soltanto un deposito.
Per usare le parole di Fred Madison nel film Strade perdute di David Lynch, preferisco ricordare le cose a modo mio, non necessariamente come sono avvenute.
Elogio della dimenticanza, di Bertolt Brecht.
Buona cosa è la dimenticanza.
Altrimenti come farebbe il figlio ad allontanarsi dalla madre che lo ha allattato?
Che gli ha dato la forza delle membra e lo trattiene per metterle alla prova?
Oppure come farebbe l'allievo ad abbandonare il maestro che gli ha dato il sapere?
Quando il sapere è dato, l'allievo deve mettersi in cammino.
Nella casa vecchia prendono alloggio i nuovi inquilini.
Se vi fossero rimasti quelli che l'hanno costruita, la casa sarebbe troppo piccola.
La stufa riscalda.
Il fumista non si sa più chi sia.
L'aratore non riconosce la forma di pane.
Come si alzerebbe l'uomo al mattino senza l'oblio della notte che cancella le tracce?
Chi è stato sbattuto a terra sei volte, come potrebbe risollevarsi la settima per rivoltare il suolo pietroso, per rischiare il volo nel cielo?
La fragilità della memoria dà forza agli uomini.
Bene, spero con questo episodio di essermi fatto perdonare per l'assenza, ma soprattutto spero che tu abbia apprezzato la splendida interpretazione della divina Yolanda Granato, che ha declamato per noi la poesia Elogio della Dimenticanza.
Io non posso che ringraziarla ancora e ribadire anche qui che sono onorato di avere in questo progetto una delle voci più amate del panorama del doppiaggio italiano, nonché una delle mie voci preferite in assoluto.
Yolanda ha doppiato personaggi iconici dei videogames, serie tv e film con interpretazioni magnifiche.
Da Nova di Starcraft 2 a Junker Queen di Overwatch passando per Friday in Avengers, da Ino Yamanaka in Naruto a Lamu passando per Aggretsuko.
Ma io l'ho letteralmente adorata in Gintama, in cui ha doppiato il personaggio di Kagura dandole un carisma e una simpatia incredibili.
Quindi che dire, ancora grazie Yolanda di tutto.
E tu che mi ascolti trovi in descrizione il link al suo profilo Instagram dove pubblica reels e storie super divertenti e alla pagina che parla di lei su Wikipedia se sei curioso di saperne di più sulla sua attività di doppiatrice.
Tornando a pensieri in codice, però, so che è venuto fuori un episodio lunghetto e non leggerissimo, ma era un argomento che mi frullava in testa da un bel po', e volevo provare a spiegare il mio punto di vista nella maniera più chiara possibile.
Ovviamente mi interessa anche sapere tu cosa ne pensi.
Ti è piaciuto il mio ragionamento?
Sei d'accordo oppure no?
Hai qualcosa da aggiungere?
Se ti va scrivimi, oppure meglio ancora, passa nel gruppo Telegram di Pensieri in Codice e raccontaci la tua.
Trovi tutti i contatti nella descrizione dell'episodio e sul sito pensierincodice.it con due i.
E se hai quell'amico o amica fissati con il rileggere i messaggi e fare mille fotografie, giragli l'episodio, chissà che non ne possa venire fuori un confronto interessante.
Prima di salutarci, come sempre, ti ricordo, velocissimamente giuro, che Pensieri in Codice è un progetto indipendente che porto avanti nel mio tempo libero e che si basa sulla filosofia del value for value.
Detto super semplicemente significa che se quello che ascolti ti dà un qualcosa, uno spunto, una riflessione, un'informazione interessante, anche solo un momento di intrattenimento, allora puoi scegliere, volontariamente si intende, di restituire parte di quel valore.
Puoi farlo con il tuo tempo, condividendo l'episodio sui social o con qualcuno a cui pensi possa interessare.
Oppure puoi farlo con il tuo talento, partecipando al progetto e dando una mano o proponendo idee.
oppure ancora, se vuoi, anche con un piccolo supporto economico.
Tutti i riferimenti a questi vari metodi li trovi sul sito pensierincodice.it slash sostieni.
In questo episodio un grazie di cuore va a Michele, Giuseppe, Patrizia, Edoardo, Carlo e Christian.
che hanno contribuito con le loro donazioni.
Alcuni di loro andrebbero ringraziati anche più volte, ma prometto che cercherò di essere più regolare con le pubblicazioni.
In realtà ho mille idee, ma da qualche mese faccio un po' fatica a riorganizzare e scrivere gli episodi.
Poi la prossima puntata è la 150 e quindi dobbiamo pensare a qualcosa di speciale, no?
Ma per oggi direi che è tutto, visto?
Sono stato velocissimo più o meno.
Noi ci sentiamo al prossimo episodio, io ti ringrazio per aver ascoltato fino alla fine, ti saluto e ti ricordo sempre che un informatico risolve problemi, a volte anche usando il computer.